you know one of the biggest scams
perpetrated and perpetuated by the
american right
is that they are the patriotic ones they
are the ones who support the troops
they are the ones who support the police
police they are the ones who are about
america first
and as if you needed more proof that
this is an utter and pathetic
lie over the last 24 hours we have seen
first of all republicans right-wingers
and right-wing media hosts
root literally root against the united
states in the olympics
rooting against the women's soccer team
or rooting
for other countries to win uh make
fun of gymnast simone biles
for her pulling out of competition
yesterday slash the day before yesterday
with the time
difference with tokyo i don't know
exactly when it was over the last 24 to
36 hours
making fun of her uh not exactly america
first patriotic behavior
um in terms of how you would uh relate
to
or discuss someone who's halfway around
the world representing the united states
in athletic competition and then
yesterday after the first day
of testimony of the house select
committee investigating the january 6
trump riots
after four police officers whose
lives were threatened as they attempted
to defend the capitol on january 6th
widely republicans and right-wing media
hosts
ridiculed the police officers and
laughed at the police officers
and made a mockery of the things that
they said
in their testimony yesterday we're going
to look at some clips and just
remember when you look at this they say
they support police
they say they defend law enforcement
they call themselves patriotic
here is tucker carlson literally
chuckling at the things we heard from
one of the officers
officer fanon yesterday look at this
people he doesn't agree with in
washington and that is unacceptable and
it should make you very nervous
watch fanon cite the psychological
trauma he endured
as an excuse for ditching our bill of
rights yeah
i've been left with the psychological
trauma and the emotional anxiety of
having survived
such a horrific event
a very dismissive chuckle from tucker
carlson
this guy we're supposed to believe he's
a patriot and that he supports the
troops and he supports police
except when he doesn't because it's just
really not convenient it's really not
convenient because if you say wow we
should listen to the testimony of these
officers
it uh implies some really horrible
things
about the people who participated in
those trump riots next
here is a clip from newsmax this is host
grant stinkfield grant
has never been a law enforcement officer
didn't serve in the military
but he refers to republican congressman
adam kinzinger who
is a veteran as a pansy and then he
mocks
another capital police officer when the
police officer
told us that he thought he was actually
going to die on january 6th
let's look at the next clip and later on
from other law enforcement agencies
i'm afraid to think what could have
happened on january 6.
so grant that's a pretty good question
do you expect that this will answer that
question or pursue it further
no i love that he's reading the
statement i think the statement may have
actually backfired on him because you
know the leader of the capitol police
really
is nancy pelosi by the way what does it
mean i love that he's reading the
statement
is that like a dig at that officer is
from the dominican republic
is it a dig at the guy's english
language proficiency i don't i don't
even know what it means
that he says i love that he's reading it
like oh if he wasn't reading it he
wouldn't be able to speak i don't even
understand what that means
so you've got to ask nancy pelosi about
why they didn't have the backup they
so-called needed but you know heather as
i watched this hearing
they told us it wasn't going to be
political and then i got this pansy of a
congressman adam kinzinger
crying as if uh he can't hold it
together here
um it's nonsensical it's about the most
political thing i've ever seen
it is all theater typical to democratic
fashion
it is all based in emotion i'm having a
real hard time
believing a lot of what i'm hearing
because the video doesn't back
up nearly all of it one officer said he
thought it was gonna be the moment he
died
well there were no guns at this place
i've watched
guns at black lives matter protests and
riots i've watched
bricks being thrown at officers during
black lives now this was addressed
extensively and there was not only a
very long list of weapons
described by the officers but also
officers described the the belief that
there there were firearms there um
although we should be glad
that the protesters didn't start
shooting that's something to be happy
about not indignant about
as matter antifa riots i didn't see any
of that during this so
this is going to be a partisan event
brace yourselves
i refuse to lead my show with it tonight
we will most certainly talk about it
but there's no way i am giving this sham
of a hearing
uh the do of being at the top of my
program
yeah so stinkfield will be talking about
it but he's not going to lead the show
with it very principled and defiant uh
a dis production decision there by by
grant stingfield
um not very deferential to police not
back the blue not the thin blue line
it's none of that stuff all of a sudden
because they only care about that when
it's convenient
here's republican congressman jim banks
this is one of the guys that nancy
pelosi said no you're not going to be on
this panel
he is blaming the police for what
happened on january 6.
wow today was the first day again
tragic stories from capitol police
officers experiences that never
should have happened right if the
leadership of the capitol police and
those who oversaw the capitol police
would have done their job leading up to
january 6.
we would have trained the capitol police
officers so what happened to the police
on january 6th
is the fault of the police because of
what they didn't do
leading up to january 6th i see it's
the the fact that trump incited a riot
and then they rioted
and they beat police officers with
flagpoles
and bear spray and all this different
stuff it's the fault of the police guys
remember this guy supports the police
he's he's all very much pro law
enforcement would have given them better
equipment
we would have we would have warned them
about the intelligence report and i
believe that
january 6 would have been a lot
different if the capitol police
leadership would have done their job
if there would have been true leadership
at the top and oversight that didn't
happen and why are those questions not
allowed to be asked
on this committee what is the speaker
trying to hide by not allowing me and
jim jordan in the room to ask questions
about exactly well jim jordan we're
going to talk about a little bit later
but it's
it's becoming increasingly clear that
jim jordan has no place on that
committee because he's an accomplice
he can't possibly investigate it because
he appears to have been an accomplice
and we'll get to that a little bit later
jim banks of course also voted not to
certify the election
uh part of uh perpetuating the big lie
these people are truly disgusting and
then lastly
here is laura ingram from fox news she
actually had
the gall to call the um
testimony from the officer's
performances
and ridiculed them by giving out
performance awards
take a look at this i want you to get to
the bottom of that
we have more on him in a moment but it's
not about politics at all
and for best performance in an action
role the winner is
michael fanon too many are now telling
me that hell doesn't exist
or that hell actually wasn't that bad
the indifference shown to my colleagues
is disgraceful all right so laura ingram
making a mockery of the entire thing
and uh this is the movement that claims
they support police
this is the movement that claims that
they are the defenders of law
enforcement
but that's only when it's convenient to
them these people are
really disgusting like many people i
know
i've struggled with issues like i strain
from looking at a computer screen for
many hours of the day my work involves
working with a computer
and there are studies that suggest that
the blue light from screens
can cause headaches or cause you to
strain your eyes or even cause trouble
sleeping
at night but i haven't had any of those
problems since i picked up a pair of
blue blocks glasses which filter out
that blue light
that comes from the computer screen from
the phone screen from the tv screen
so i was really excited when they became
a sponsor blue blocks is a company
you can trust because their glasses were
developed in actual
optics laboratories unlike a lot of the
cheap knockoff
mass-produced stuff and because my blue
blocks glasses are blocking out that
blue light
i'm not getting the eye strain i'm not
getting the headaches i'm falling asleep
easier at night and that's the whole
point of this thing it's been a real
game changer
they have 40 different frames to choose
from there's even a prescription version
go to dot com slash pacman
and you'll get 20 off everything in
their store
plus free shipping worldwide on orders
over 115 dollars